sales are terrific out there so you're
my kind of crowd I've been getting
reports we're breaking all kinds of
Records and we're going to start off
uh
with question number 26.
which goes to station
two
I one and Charlize my name is James from
Malaysia given the reason challenge
faced by the major U.S Bank
what is your overall outlook on the
banking industry how do you assess the
risk and the opportunity in this section
well
anticipating a few questions on banks
I decided we should start using Bank
language here to describe
[Music]
Charlie
[Applause]
the
the situation
in banking is
is
very similar to what it's always been in
banking that
that fear is contagious
always
and
historically
sometimes the fear was justified
and sometimes it wasn't my dad
lost his job in 1931 because of a bank
run
and they had a bank run on the State
Banks
and uh
the head of the Omaha National Bank said
well we're a national bank and they
didn't have a run on the National Banks
and of course they both face the same
problem so it
it used to be
that
if you saw people lining up at a bank
the proper response was to get into the
line
and uh
you'll always leave it and the story is
that Sydney weiberg of Goldman Sachs
during one of the great Bank runs
um back in 1907 or thereabouts had a job
as a runner Goldman Sachs and asked us a
boss if he could
take the week off and
your boss said sure not much is going on
anyway so he got in line
whether it's a Knickerbocker trust or
wherever
and as he got toward the front of the
line he sold his place in line to
somebody he didn't have an account of
the bank but that was an asset
and uh
the banking system has changed so much
over the years and we did something
enormously sensible in my view
uh when we set up the FDIC
as many as 2 000 banks have failed in
one year back after World War one I mean
Bank
runs were just part of the picture and
if you have people that are worried
about whether their money is safe in the
bank and all signed withdrawals you
can't run an economy very well so the
FDIC was very logical it got changed
over the years some
but here we are
in
you know 2000
and
we actually see
the FDIC pay off for the 100 cents on
the dollar to everybody or
make it available on all demand deposits
and yet you still have
people very worried
about their the
periodically
geographically all kinds of crazy ways
and that just shouldn't happen so the
messaging
has been very poor
it's been poured by the politicians who
sometimes have an interest in having it
poor it's been poor by the agencies and
I'd say it's been poor by the Press I
mean you shouldn't have so many people
that misunderstand the fact
that
although there may be a debt ceiling
it's going to get changed although
there's a 250 000 limit on FDIC the FDIC
uh in the U.S government and American
public have no interest in having a bank
fail and have deposits
actually lost by people
we had a demonstration project
the weekend of Silicon Valley Bank and
the public is still confused so it
really
something to have a law that was passed
in 19th or a law that became effective
in 1934 although modified in some ways
not understood
about something as important
as a banking system I don't think the
American public is that dumb
and I just uh
well I made that offer over in Tokyo
incidentally that I haven't heard from
anybody that wants to take up my Million
Dollar Bet on on whether the public will
lose money in in in
if they have a demand deposit uh at the
bank no matter what the size so
that's the world we live in
it means that
a lot of match can turn into a
conflagration or it can be blown out and
uh who knows what will happen
and we don't have any worry we keep our
money into cash and treasures you both
at Berkshire because we keep a hundred
and
28 billion or whatever it was at the end
of the quarter and we want to be there
if
the banking system temporarily even gets
stalled in some way uh it shouldn't
I don't think it will but I think it
could and uh I think that
the incentives
in Bank regulation are are so messed up
and so many people have an interest in
having them messed up
uh
that is it's totally crazy I mean it's
the
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
we're doing 40 or so percent of the
mortgage business in the United States
that is huge they were regulated
oh just those two companies
were regulated by
some group I forget what they called it
but they had 150 people
that were in charge of just figuring out
whether funny and fatty we're doing the
right thing but I could have done it you
know it's probably it could have done it
you know and uh I'm not sure they needed
an assistant even to do it but the
incentives were all wrong and Freddie
and Fanny which we're doing fine in
August of apparently doing fine in July
and August of two thousand
eight were put into conservatorship you
know early in September and the things
that followed from that were just
incredible so
there are second order and third order
and fourth order effects uh that are
somewhat unpredictable as to what they
will be and the sequence and all that
but things change and if people think
that deposits are sticky anymore
they're just living in a different era
uh you know
press a button you don't have to get in
the line and wait for days and have the
teller counting out the money slowly and
gold so I think the line goes away you
can you you can have a running in a few
seconds so
the way it hasn't been addressed
properly is is a problem
and who knows where it leads but
you'll have to have a punishment
for the people that do the wrong thing
and
if you take First Republic for example
you could look at their 10K
and you could see that they were
offering
non-government guaranteed mortgages to
in jumbo amounts at fixed rates
sometimes for 10 years before they
change the floating and I mean that's a
crazy proposition if it's to the
advantage of the bank
they get it they get the guy coming in
and says I'll read Finance it one and a
half percent and then one percent
and if it's
Advantage the other way the fellow keeps
it out 10 years you don't give options
like that but but that's what first
Republica was doing it was a plain sight
and the world ignored it tell it blew up
and uh
uh
some of the stock in some of these banks
that were held by Insider it was a soul
and who knows whether they
had a plan or whether they some plan
that was innocent or whether they
started sensing what was coming but
but
you do know
that the directors are not going to be
able to read some
book or anything like that but they do
they do have the ability
to hold the CEO accountable CEO gets
gets the bank in trouble both the CEO
and the director should suffer
the stockholders of the future shouldn't
suffer they didn't do anything it
doesn't teach anybody any lessons or
anything it teaches the lesson is that
if you run a bank and you screw it up
you still live you're still a rich guy
and the clubs don't drop you and and the
charity groups don't quit asking it to
their benefits and the world goes on
that is not a good lesson uh to teach
people who are holding the behavior of
the economy in their hands so I think
there's some work to be done but I don't
think it's it's not a difficult problem
it's just we've screwed up the answer
and we've screwed up the communication
of it Charlie
well I'm so old-fashioned
that I kind of liked it better when
Banks didn't do investment banking
that makes me very outmoded
in the modern world
and the country decided it was contrary
to public interest for a while and then
then the banks want to get back into it
did they ever yeah no I mean I don't
think having a bunch of Bankers all of
them were trying to get rich leads to
good things
but I
I think a banker should be more like an
engineer he's more like into avoiding
trouble than he is getting rich yeah and
they could do fine they they can do fine
that way and I think we had a big
mistake when we go to the bank where
everybody who joins the funds to get
rich yeah it's a it's a contradiction
and values and we came to that
conclusion I don't know when class still
passed or anything but but then they
want to get back in
how many of you know and maybe I'm wrong
on this I haven't looked lately but the
Federal Reserve actually was given the
responsibility for setting margin
requirements and they changed margin
requirements a lot of times because it
was known that people that borrow a lot
of money cause the danger to the bank
system if you get too many in the
picture and all of that sort of thing
and uh
what's happened the banks figured out a
thousand different ways to get so you
could borrow on 100 margin you know
different I mean through through
derivatives and everything they just
totally distorted
uh every all the lessons that were
learned in the 29 crash imagine taking
banking into derivative Trading who in
his right mind would have allowed that
yeah well there's more money in it well
that's why they're in it yeah and and
and but it isn't necessarily a great
social outcome for the rest of us that's
what that's what those Senate committees
decided back in 1931 and 32 and then in
the late 1990s particularly I mean you
know very decent people but you know Bob
Rubin and some of the people that you
know they they said this is the modern
world and here's what the modern world
has turned out to hand us and uh
banking
banking can have all kinds of
of new inventions but it needs to have
old values and uh
uh well if we don't we don't know what's
going to happen you know because
uh there are a lot of things that could
happen out of the present situation
depositors will not lose money
stockholders and debt holders of the
holding company they should lose money
and the people
borrowed on out on Commercial Real
Estate and now it isn't the loans aren't
getting extended they should leave it's
too bad I mean that's part of borrowing
100 margin which is what people were
doing I've been doing in commercial real
estate you've got to have the penalties
hit the people the cause uh the problems
and if they took risks that they
shouldn't have it it needs to fall on
them if you're going to change how
people are going to behave in the future
okay Becky
this question comes from Davis Hance in
Houston Texas
he writes what do you think about the
business models of the big Banks as
compared to the regional banks in the
wake of the events at Silicon Valley
Bank and how does the perceived implicit
guarantee of all deposits that all banks
affect big Banks and those Regional
Banks yeah well I I
I can say this
if if you found if you follow sound
banking methods which means not doing
some things that other people do
a bank could be a perfectly decent
investment in fact Charlie and I
was me originally in 1969 we bought a
bank at Berkshire
and we had 19 million dollars invested
in that bank and we had 17 million I
think invested in our insurance
companies and if the banking
holding company Act of 1970 hadn't been
passed we might have ended up owning a
lot of banks instead of a lot of
insurance companies we were looking at
more Banks and Harry Kip was taking us
around Chicago and there were other
things we could do and then bingo they
passed the 1970 uh Bank holding company
act and we had to divest ourselves of
that bank in in in 10 years which by the
way had never had a bad debt oh it never
had an unnecessary cost it made nothing
but money with no risk and never
presented any Deposit Insurance risk to
the government zero it was a lovely
sound constructive institution in this
community and any person who really
deserved credit could get credit and we
were going to buy more we were forced
out of it and we were going to buy more
Banks and if we bought more Banks we
probably wouldn't have been expanded the
insurance business but
you know the law changed and so we
divested and and we've done all kind of
insurance but banking was more
attractive to us it was bigger than
there were more targets uh to buy and uh
you could run a perfectly sound bank
then and uh no negotiable certificate
said all these things all the inventions
that came later and you could still run
them today and you could earn
you're gonna learn a lot you can earn
good money very good money and we didn't
we would have found more Banks but uh
were precluded from doing that
and we sold Banks Bank stocks uh in the
last well we sold them first when the
pandemic broke out and then we sold some
more in the last six months and uh uh
we don't know where
the shareholders of the big Banks
necessarily uh or the regional Banks or
anybody are heading I've got my bank
I've got my own personal money and I'm
probably above the
FDIC limited I've got it with a local
bank and I think I don't worry about it
in the least but in terms of
owning Banks
events will determine
their future and you've got politicians
involved you've got
you've got a whole a lot of people don't
really understand how the system works
uh and I would say that the event
something less than a perfect
communication
between uh
various people and the American public
so the American public is probably as
confused about
banking as ever and that has
consequences and nobody knows what the
consequences are because uh
every event
starts recreating a different Dynamic I
mean in physics you know that Pi is
going to be 3.14 you know infinite
number of numbers after that but uh no
matter what happens but you don't know
what has happened to the stickiness of
deposits at all it got changed by 2008
it's gotten Changed by this I mean it
and that changes everything and so we're
very cautious in a situation like that
about ownership
uh
A Banks and we we
do
remain with
One Bank holding a a a a deal but we
originated that deal and uh with the
Bank of America I like Bank of America I
like I I I I I I I like the management
and
I proposed the deals of them so I'm I'm
I stick with it but
do I know how to project out what's
going to happen from her the answer is I
don't because I've seen so many things
in the last
few months which really weren't that
unexpected to me to see but which
reconfirmed my beliefs that the American
public doesn't understand their banking
system
and some people in Congress perhaps
don't understand it any more than I
understand I don't understand what the
spaceships Go I mean there's all kinds
of things I don't know about
uh
if you're in Congress you've taken
position on everything and sometimes
it's to your advantage if you really
understand it not to say exactly what
you
what you feel and uh and here we are
Charlie yeah
well a lot has happened in Bengali in my
lifetime I welcomed all that early
banking of the disturbing immigrants by
the early Bank of America
and I think all the credit cards when
they came in as original bank cards were
a great contribution to civilization
and
but
the game year it gets and the more it
looks like Investment Banking the less I
like it as a citizen
I'm always
I I am deeply distrustful situations in
which everybody wants to get rich and
envies everybody else
I regard that atmosphere is utterly
toxic
and the people who like one story which
is again a true story and
I'm not naming the name and it wasn't
Pete Jeffries because he might fit this
name but it wasn't Pete but
our hero Gene abeg was going to have to
retire at some point and so we
we hired
a
future replacement it's got a little
problem I talked before about having the
perfect business and now we're going to
bring in somebody we actually bring in
some money but what does Central High
with Charlie all over my class yeah and
Charlie didn't know I was
picking up this guy and he wasn't he
didn't ask me we wouldn't hired him
well if I asked you I probably wouldn't
hire anybody but that's another question
but this guy comes over a perfectly
decent guy but presentable you know it
looks like a banker and everything
and of course the first thing he wants
to do we've got this wonderful bag but
we got the crummiest looking building in
Rockford and we don't need a great
building we just need a great banker and
naturally this guy wants to build a new
building and uh because we were the most
profitable bank but we didn't look like
we're the most problems
so I told him he could have any building
he wanted
as long as it was not higher than I'd
had to be shorter than the our nearest
competitor and he he lost interest
totally he wanted to be on the top floor
of the of the biggest building in town
and I told him to get horizontally do
anything he wanted but he couldn't do it
vertically
it taught me a lot about the guy's
motivations in life but and and he
didn't end up running the bank anyway
anyway that's all I know about banking
probably more uh station three
Mr Buffett and Mr Munger hi my name is
Daphne I'm 13 years old and this is my
sixth annual Berkshire halfway chain
controllers meeting
and I've had the privilege to ask you
both questions in years past
my question for you today is the
following
as you know the U.S national debt is
currently at an estimated 31 trillion
dollars making up about 125 percent of
the U.S GDP
in the meantime over the past few years
the Federal Reserve has telegraphed that
they intend to monetize the debt by
printing trillions of dollars even as
they insist that they're fighting
inflation
already other major economies in the
world such as China Saudi Arabia and
Brazil are moving away from the dollar
in anticipation of this
my question is are we likely to face a
time in the future when the U.S dollar
is no longer the global Reserve currency
how is Berkshire prepared for this
possibility and what can we do as
American citizens to attempt to shelter
ourselves from what's beginning to look
like the beginnings of dedolarization
well
hey
I should ask you to come up here and
answer some questions I mean
hey uh
it's very interesting I mean we are the
reserve currency and I see no option
for any other currency to be the reserve
currency and and uh
I think that
nobody understands the situation better
than Jay Paul and uh
I but he's not in control
of
of fiscal policy and every now and then
he drops a few hints uh and there was no
question that when the
when when when the pandemic broke out I
mean it was a semi-warl-like situation
but
nobody knows
how far you can go
with the paper currency before it gets
out of control
if and particularly if you're the
reserve world's Reserve currency Nobody
Knows the answer to that
and you don't want to try and pick out
the point at where it does become a
problem because then it's all over uh
and I think we should be
very careful I mean you know we all
learned keynesianism and we applied in
World War Two to the advantage of the
country and and we did everything we
could to prevent inflation during the
war
and then the war ended in August the 45
and I think in January 46 and I'm not
giving you exact figures at all now but
in January 46 I think the rate of
inflation was it
you know something like one percent or
thereabouts and by the end of the year I
think it was like 15 and again I'm doing
this from long memories but but
it's
it's easy
for America
to do what's
a lot
but if we do too much
it's very hard
to see how you recover
once you let the genie out of the bottle
and people lose faith in the currency
and they behave in an entirely different
manner
than they do when they feel that if they
put some money in the bank or have a
pension planned or whatever it may be
that they're going to get to have
something with roughly equal purchasing
power and it just changes legal economy
and all kinds of things can happen then
and I can't predict them and nobody else
can predict them but I do know they
aren't good and uh
we will see
and I I do this as my you know I I voted
for both parties and it's it's uh
it's not limited to politicians of
either party or anything of the sort uh
uh people
take positions some of them understand
what they're doing some don't understand
what they're doing uh and uh you know if
they put me on
some Medical Board I don't understand
what I'm doing you know it's not there's
nothing wrong with the fact that you
that
you can't master everything can all be
Isaac Newton but but you can't go around
pretending you do or making decisions on
it and and we
are not as well off in relationship to
curbing inflation expectations which
become self-fulfilling
uh
um we are not as well off as we were
earlier and Berkshire
is better prepared than most Investments
for that kind of a period but I said
this in the annual report but we aren't
perfectly prepared because there's no
there's no way to perfectly prepare you
don't know what course of action
will occur and
uh
it's a very political decision now it's
a tribal decision to some degree uh and
uh you'll hope for leadership
that that uh
actually
will do something recognizes the problem
and
America's an incredible Society Rich you
know every we got everything going for
us but that doesn't mean we can just
print money indefinitely that
as as that and uh
uh it'll be interesting to see how it
turns out Charlie
well at some point
ing money to buy votes will be
counterproductive yep and we don't we
don't know exactly where that comes
and if something is going to be
dangerous and unproductive you ought to
keep it a fair distance away
now if you have a culture that is
exceptionally strong like Japan
they have done some strange things there
but they couldn't have been the reserve
currency no of course not and but Japan
brought back most of the national debt
and most of a lot of the Common Stocks
and that just the Federal Reserves
practically everything in Japan and the
countries working
it's in in 30 years of economic stasis
but it's not going to hell
I really admire Japan
and but I don't think we should try and
imitate it
I don't think we're as good as good as
Japan at taking
they have a cohesive culture and we
don't Charlie that's exactly right
in Japan everybody's supposed to suck it
up and cope and
in America we've been playing
so I hope you come next year with a
tougher question
but and thank you and I I predict I
would love to be being born again today
in the United States I mean we
we can do a we can do a lot of dumb
things and get away with it we can't do
an unlimited number there are people who
care about that and uh you know
you have to be willing to be
extraordinarily
unpopular I mean Paul volcker uh there
were there are other Federal Reserve
chair people that would not have not
have done what they did it's just it's
it's too uncomfortable and uh
uh
there used to be a politician in
Nebraska and if you ask them some really
tough question like you know how do you
stand on abortion or he would look you
right in the eye and say I'm all right
on that one and then he moved next door
well that's what people have done
basically on inflation and they they one
way or another they uh they say I'm all
right on that and then they they don't
really think about what the consequences
of their actions could be
particularly and it's so much fun if
there's 435 of you it'll just be one of
435 instead of being the person actually
responsible anyway I am still
next to the
question of two superpowers and when you
get into really destroying a planet
destroying
the reserve currency of the world when
there's really no substance and
forgettable all the toys you know with
with I mean it's a joke uh to think of
any tokens or
of that sort of that that that's Madness
but but it's also Madness to just keep
printing money yeah and
we know how to do it and we actually
came from a money pretty money printing
economy
in World War II which was required
and we suffered significant inflation
the price level
I mean there's a million ways to judge
it but maybe 10 times what it was then
or something like that well that's
that's getting close to the edge of
where you don't want to
you don't want old dollars anymore you
want to hold something else uh I want to
hold real estate you want an old
interest in a business there's a lot of
good ones your best your best
defense is your own earning power if
you're the best doctor in town if you're
the best lawyer in town if you have a
teacher in town or even if it's the 10th
ambassador
you're going to make a good living I
mean uh
you know the economy is productive and
you will succeed
with your talents but you won't succeed
by hoarding dollars you'll just be
you'll just succeed by the fact that
you're
your value to the community which is a
rich Community overall is sustained and
so the best investment is always in
yourself that that's the answer I would
give you
well we have a situation where we've
learned to print money
in gobs and a little a big chunk of our
young people go right into Wealth
Management
this is like we did yeah like we did yes
we've been bad examples and I want to
say that I didn't realize wealth
management was going to get so big when
I went into it and I also apologize for
what's happened
yeah well
anyway you did well
Becky this question comes from Gary
Gambino in Parma Ohio who says he's been
a Berkshire shareholder since 2004. he
says the amount paid this year for the
41.4 stake in Pilot values the entire
company at around 19 billion dollars
that's about six times what BP is paying
for Travel Centers of America but
Pilot's market share is Just Three Times
Travel Centers of America's was it a big
mistake to base the final price on 2022
earnings which has unusually high fuel
margins well that's a very good question
and the answer is
that we arranged to buy it in three
stages
uh with the third stage being at the
option of these owner of twenty percent
the first stage we we bought it what
turned out to be a very attractive price
the second stage turned out to be a very
good year for the diesel business which
means that the seller got a very good
price and I would say that overall we
feel very good about the fact we only 80
percent at the price that we do but we
would have rather owned a better if we
just bought the 80 to start with and the
last 20 percent the seller has the
option and that's always uh an
unintelligent way of structuring
something we've had that arrangement
with other well we've had it with the
furniture mart we bought 80 percent of
the Furniture Mart on August 30th
1983 almost 40 years ago and it's worked
out perfectly but uh when you give the
other person the option they've got some
Advantage we we have 80 novel business
we like very much
and the comparison to travel America is
really
Superior because Travel America not only
much smaller but they run all their
properties we have hundreds and hundreds
of locations on the interstate that are
zoned for what we commercial and maybe
15 Acres or there's nothing like it and
they're not going to move the interstate
two miles to the right or something and
then you know the swords so we've got a
position that that uh
travel I mean you know BP may have may
or may not have made a fine deal I'd
read the prospectus uh and I can
understand I mean it's a big big source
of output for for BP but
uh I like I like the management we have
had at the at at uh pilot I like very
much the followers coming in uh that's
the new CEO
uh uh I just have to tell you a little
bit about Adam Wright who's taking that
job on he came from Omaha he wasn't
selected because he came from Omaha he
came from Omaha he came from North High
that a public school and my wife
graduated from I've got
grandchildren that graduated from there
he went to the University of Nebraska to
almost set the rushing record uh in
football which will never be beaten
because they've given up football but I
think he rushed for maybe
3 600 or he held three jobs
while he went through there he interned
at Mid-American 20 years ago his mother
worked to put him through school I mean
it's just it's Horatio Alger squared
and we have him to manage pilot and the
aslams of giving us a wonderful business
they
Big Jim you know he he uh my advantage I
mean great people and here we are uh and
I'm glad I'm very glad we owned pilot I
just wish we bought 100 percent of it
when I first made the deal but that was
not the deal where it wasn't for sale it
wasn't for sale yeah
and and then suddenly the last 20
percent of
of of the Furniture Mart wasn't for sale
when we bought so we bought 80 of it and
that's worked out well and and we've
done various deals various ways the best
way to do it is just write people to
check and and get the stock was we did
that with TTI but but
you can't always make the same deal we
make we find if we like the business
well enough and the people well enough
we we will tailor it differently but our
preference is to write a check and own
the whole place and and
keep the management in place
no
yeah I hope
it's really wonderful to watch something
like Adam wrightwork I mean the
basically you know I don't know what
his mother was earning but but
he went to North High which is
probably four or five miles from here
public school graduate
and worked his way up
went for a short period of Pacific
Gas and Electric
and we brought them home
to run pilot
and pilot
well pilot the prices on diesel were way
different last year I brought Pilots
close to 80 billion of sales last year
but
more normal prices it's
it's a
significant and you know it's half that
or thereabouts and maybe a little more
but
he is
I don't know how old Adam would be but
it's in his 40s and and he came up
through
he came up through the organization that
Greg Abel was involved with and and now
here he is
running a very major business it's good
I'd for sure to be able to do that and
uh
I don't you know
somebody else may have gone to warp
press stitches
Business Schools or anything so what you
know we've seen what Adam can do
okay
station four
good afternoon Mr Buffett Mr Munger my
name is JC I'm 15 years old and I'm from
Ohio
this is my fourth in-person Berkshire
meeting I have a lot of passion learning
from your speeches interviews and
articles thank you for sharing your
wisdom all the time
Mr Buffett in your annual shareholder
letter this year you said that
berkshire's Journey consisted of
continuous savings the power of
commanding the American tailwind and
avoidance of major mistakes
you have humbly admitted in the past
that you have made many mistakes
but this is the first time that major
mistakes stood out to me
could you please advise us on what major
mistakes we should learn we should avoid
in both investing and in life
I would also like to have Mr munger's
thoughts too please thank you very much
Charlie Charlie said the major mistake
you can make then you know you're you're
lucky if you're in the United States
people around the world they don't have
a lot of choices some in some places but
but
you should you should write your
obituary and try and figure out how to
live up to it uh and uh
you know that's that's something you get
wiser on as you
uh go along the business mistakes
uh you just want to make sure you don't
make any mistakes to take out of the
game or come close to taking out of your
game you should never have a night when
you're worried about
investing I mean assuming you have any
money to invest at all and you should
you should get to spend a little bit
less than you earn and you can spend a
little bit more than you earn and then
then you've got debt and the chances are
you'll never get out of debt I'll make
an exception in terms of of a mortgage
on your house but but
credit card debt and we're in the credit
card business big time and the board
will stay in the credit card business
but why get behind the game and if
you're effectively paying 12 or 14 or
whatever percent you're paying on a
credit card you know you're saying I'm
going to earn more than 12 14 of money
and if you can do that come to Berkshire
Hathaway so it uh
it's it's I hate to say this for
Charlie's around me but it's straight
out of Ben Franklin
and uh uh
it's not
it's not that complicated
but
uh
you well I'll I'll give you a couple
lessons on you know Tom Murphy the first
time I met him
said
two things to me said you know always
tell someone to go to hell tomorrow well
that was great advice then and think
about great advice it is when you when
you sit down on the computer and screw
your life on Forever by by telling
somebody to go to hell or something else
in 30 seconds and you can't erase it uh
and you know you haven't lost the option
you know and and then and he said you
know praise praise my name criticized by
category well what makes more sense than
that I mean who do you like to
criticizes you all the time and uh
you don't need to
you don't need Abilify anybody to make
your point on on on subjects of
discussion and and uh and then they give
you another General
piece of advice I'm I've never known
anybody that was basically kind that
died without friends and uh I've known
plenty of people with money that who
died without friends uh including their
family and uh but I've never known
anybody and then and uh
you know I've seen a few people
including Tom Murphy Senior and and
maybe Junior who's here
certainly his dad uh he I never saw him
I watched him for 50 years I never saw
him do
an unkind act I didn't I didn't seem to
do it very many stupid acts either I
mean it wasn't it was not a
discriminating he just
uh he just decided that um that there
was no reason to do it and uh
wow what a difference that makes in life
Charlie
well it's it's so simple
to
spend less than you
earn and
industrially and avoid toxic people and
toxic activities and
try and keep learning all your life etc
etc
and do a lot of deferred gratification
because you prefer life that way
and if
if you do all those things you are
almost certain to succeed
and if you don't
you're going to need a lot of luck a lot
of luck
and you don't want to need a lot of luck
you want to go into a game where you're
very likely to win without having any
unusual luck
I'd add one more thought too I you need
to know
how people can manipulate other people
then you need to resist the temptation
to do it yourself oh yes the
the toxic people
who are trying to fool you or lie to you
who aren't reliable meeting their
commitments
a great lesson of life is get the hell
out of your life
and do it fast
do it fast
and I would add
would Charlie wouldn't totally agree
with me do it tactfully if possible too
but do get them out of your life
yes yeah I don't mind a little tact
or even a little Financial cost but the
question is getting the hell out of the
lot
okay Becky
all right this comes from Roger uh lee
town
he says my name is Roger from Hong Kong
a long-term shareholder of Berkshire
admirer and follower of Mr Buffett's
amonger's wisdom and principle both of
you have said before that the most
difficult problems in life are always
people problems and one of the key
lessons you have learned to be able to
live a happy life in a successful life
is to stay away from negative people my
question is what to do if those negative
people are your families the people
whom you can't simply stay away from
yeah
you minimize it
but you
can't I mean there's no question about
it but Charlie gave an answer I thought
was a master of attack the other day
whether he says you always
how would I interact with people who
behave well he says of course you have
to make some exceptions to your family
but that's
it was
but it's true and uh you know you really
I don't know what it's like
to have you know
a drunken
you know bullish
uh
but probably father but parents just
generally I mean it you know how do you
handle it and uh
it's very interesting that
the MacArthur family
uh the very famous John MacArthur the
battle set up the MacArthur Foundation
uh he had five kids
and four of them turned out to be
superstars of one sort or another and
they had this crazy generous drunken
father but they all decided the thing to
do was get the hell out of the house
and so yeah this
the father of the MacArthur Foundation
that did that along with three of the
siblings out of five cell
you know I
I was lucky I mean Charlie was lucky
at uh
it uh
you know if you
if you have a I mean her father saw
plenty of shortcomings and
and and both of us but you know it would
still be there for us
and if you have one that won't be there
for you you know I uh it's a very tough
problem and I think one way or another
I probably would have gotten through
with that through that if I had that
situation but
I don't think I think my life would have
been a lot different Charlie
I I have nothing to add but we're
okay station five
hey wadden I'm childless
good afternoon my name is
Arkansas Home of Walmart I'm her
shareholders since 2019 and my daughters
are shareholder since 2020.
my question is
this is my first time coming to
shareholders and my question is
relationship
with BNSF McLean and consumer goods like
Fruit of the Looms and granimals and Etc
my question is granules is exclusively
sold at Walmart and Fruit of the Loom is
sold at many other retailers how does
Berkshire hathway decides some items are
sold at some retailers exclusively
versus others are sold at many retailers
well that's a good question but
obviously
you'd love to control if you have a
product you'd love to control the
distribution and you're probably going
to get
better gross margins if they ask for you
by name I mean they just had an article
about Bernardo Arnold oh
lvmh and you know he's got a blue box of
Tiffany and the blue box itself means
something and
a Coca-Cola the bottle I met something
in the 1920s I think there was a study
of that
kind of hook shirt bottle and blindfold
with a very high percentage of the
population could recognize it was
Coca-Cola when they can recognize not
only the the product was a container uh
you know you're going to have good gross
margins and if you're just another Cola
and there have been hundreds of them uh
and even if you have distribution
through something like Walmart who has
Sam's Cola
it just doesn't it's not the same I mean
here I am you know and
1886 or so John Pemberton in Atlanta
uh created it and they they spent very
significant amount of money advertising
on the other hand Hershey's didn't spend
any money on Advertising so
we have observed
Charlie and I both have observe so many
products so many methods of retail and
we really think
we know quite a bit a lot of it and we
we also know how much we don't know
about it at the same time and it doesn't
mean that we want to going to retailing
ourselves but it does mean
we've learned to some extent what to
avoid
uh and we've learned when somebody
really has something Incredibles have
something it's just that there's only
many you know at Walmart does a great
job of distribution for us and it's a
good product for Walmart it's a good
product for us and
uh on Fruit of the Loom uh they can
solve lots of types of underwear and
they can do a big volume but we're not
going to
make as much money rather simply to
Capital employed or anything
with a product that uh that has a whole
bunch of competitors and if the kid
wants to go animals uh pajamas or
something uh it's not it's not the sort
of product that causes people to drive
20 miles out of their way to buy it or
anything of the sort but if you're in
the Walmart and you're you're picking
out pajamas or something for the kid and
and
he or she wants
a particular product
and it's not and it's reasonably priced
and everything and wears well whenever
you know we will
we're happy to have it distributed
through somebody with a distribution
power of Walmart and their design
they're very happy to have the product
uh
unbalance is obviously better if you own
See's Candy then if you own the no-name
candy company uh
you know particularly women
people buy it as gifts a couple times a
year I mean they they know that if they
give
if they give them
their girlfriend if they give someone in
the hospital if they give a gift to
Christmas or going to a dinner
they know if they hand the box of candy
to somebody they don't say at the same
time here I got a wonderful deal on this
candy I mean had some kills the moment
right what they really want to see is a
smile on the other person's face that
they're receiving it and they get it so
uh knowing what customers and
season box chocolates a are not remotely
the market that soft drinks are and
the product
does not travel particularly Hershey's
chocolate is in trouble I mean if you
look at candy bars what's popular in the
UK isn't that popular in the US and all
kinds of things
Coca-Cola travels there's 200 countries
and roughly in probably 180 of them it's
the nominal product and uh
how do you do it well it helps if you
started in 1886
from that point forward
so we've learned a lot we've got a lot
to learn
but
we did learn that something like our
animals we understood
when it came around nobody ever heard of
it we bought it for
very low price as it turned out in 20
years ago and still Nobody Knows It
hardly that we own it and that's fine
but they know what Garanimals are and
and
it has legs it keeps it just keeps going
year after year and some some things are
like pet rocks and and we're learning
all the time
Charlie
I have nothing to add okay
you probably have never bought anything
around them also no I never
I don't even wear them
[Laughter]
okay Becky
this question comes from Barry Laffer in
New York City
Berkshire owns about 94 million shares
of Paramount Global as of the last
published data this asset rich company
is disappointed on recent quarterly
earnings reports and just this week
slashed its dividend by 80 percent how
do you see the streaming Wars evolving
and do you still have conviction in your
investment thesis
is your investment thesis based on the
company being an acquisition Target or
based on its fundamentals yeah and and
how how would you like to manage my
money for nothing
they we are not in the business of of uh
giving
stock advice to people and people who
don't know anything about stocks can
make a lot of money doing that and we
don't think it's something we should
give away
but I will say this it's not good news
when any company passes a dividend or
because it's dividend dramatically and
the streaming business is extremely
interesting to watch because there's
people people love to use their eyeballs
watching being entertained on on a
screen in front of them or a phone or
whatever it may be but uh
uh there's a lot of companies doing it
and you need fewer companies or you need
higher prices and well you need higher
prices or doesn't work and you don't
lock in people when you get them to
to join up for the streaming period when
your serial runs I mean you know you
keep them on for a while but you can't
look them up and uh and
we'll see what happens I mean uh
I had a gasoline station when I was 21
or 22 and it's about
three or four months four or four or
five miles from here
and we had one competitor and and uh he
determined our profit because he
we looked at his price every day and if
we cut the price he'd match it and we
couldn't raise the price and he did
twice the gallery so he won and
there's just basic business problems
that you
see with certain injuries because you
don't
see what the other Disney was unique
uh
and it's animated what it offered you
know in the 30s and 40s and and they
wrote the stuff off and then the first
showing and then they they rejuvenated
Snow White and all these other people
every seven years and
that was fine but this is a different
world and uh and the eyeballs aren't
going to increase dramatically in the
time they can spend or it's not going to
increase dramatically and you gotta open
which is companies that don't want to
quit and uh
who knows what pricing does under that
but anybody tells you what they know
what pricing will do in the future
as as getting themselves Charlie
's had a lot of experience incidentally
with Hollywood I mean he used to before
I even met him uh I think the movie
business is one tough business yeah
that's my view the talent will make the
money the agents will make the money and
if you've got a theater
you know the theaters are now
doing 70 percent of the business that
they did
before the pandemic and big hits you
know you have enormous grosses but
you can't reduce the supply
people have only got so many
so many hours in the day they've only
got two eyeballs and and they got more
Choice than ever before and they've got
substance cheaper that uh offers them
the same experience and not some of them
like to experience you know particularly
the big hits of going and but
it isn't like you can double the number
of people or double the eyeballs or
anything like that and and you've got a
lot of people the talent will always get
paid and uh when you essentially are
packaging that Talent one way or another
uh and you need to get higher prices and
you've got a lot of strong companies
that don't want to quit uh that's an
interesting
an interesting equation hey if you think
the movies are tough try to invest in a
New York show I don't know if a
conventional stage
there they think it's a breach of faith
in that business to let the person put
up the money ever get any money back
yeah
yeah well Charlie saw a lot of that
actually yeah I
like those businesses don't tell them
what happened on Cleopatra Charlie
no it it uh
it's a business that everybody's tempted
they love the idea of going in it you
know and they get a certain amount of
psychic income but uh but I never owned
any resources either
well I my father and I and I used to
talk about claiming a horse in the
carbon button we never quite got around
to it and we had a lot of fun to wear
the track together
okay section six
good afternoon my name is Hannah Hayes
and I'm a high schooler from Iowa
you said earlier today that
transitioning to renewable energy has
the people and capital to support it so
with enough investment and Renewables
the development of energy storage
technology to soon meet Iowa's energy
needs and support from the government
system through inflation reduction act
funding why hasn't Berkshire Hathaway
energy truly invested in the future by
accelerating retirement plans for the
coal plants which have high operating
costs and are currently Iowa's biggest
carbon polluter and will continue to be
until they're finally retired in 2049
which is too late to be curbing
emissions according to the ipcc and it's
very interesting we
the
in Iowa
we have actually produced more
uh
wind energy than is used
the term amount of energy used by our
our customers but it's not
it's not producible 24 hours a day
necessarily so the there's problems and
incidentally in in Iowa
a significant majority of
counties welcome us when we come around
and want to put in wind and some don't
want it I mean it it you know it is it
is a there's a knot in my backyard
someplace there's other places where
they love the money they get from a
small pot of grounds and and people in
the like the taxes that are paid but I
would say that if there's
one state in the Union that stands out
in the development it's
it's Iowa but what's also interesting in
Iowa is that we have one
other major company there's always loads
of little co-ops and all kinds of things
that sell electricity but we have one
major competitor and uh our prices are
uh significantly lower and as a matter
of fact
we are now in the Omaha Public Power
District and three miles or four miles
away we're selling electricity in Iowa
and
we are selling it cheaper even though
Public Power was invented
in Nebraska and has been a uh
I think it's George Norris did it back
in the 1930s and
you know it's it uh it's Nebraska's
resisted to some extent uh wind power
more than Iowa but like I said our
competitor or Alternate Source hasn't
really pursued it the way we have but
I wouldn't I would say that our record
in wind and solar
has not been taught by any hotel in the
United States and of course
it's been aided by the fact
that most utilities pay out 70 or 80
percent of earnings and dividends and uh
uh we haven't taken a common dividend
out of we had a little tiny preferred we
haven't taken a common dividend of you
know for 20 years we reinvested I don't
know how many billions that's the reason
why their earnings have gone from
200 million to 4 billion but we're not
earning a higher rate of return on
Capital than we were when we started we
just put way more Capital into the
businesses we went along kept
reinvesting the capital so
I wish Greg were to tell you more
details about it but but uh but uh
I would say that we'd put up we'd really
put a Berkshire Hathaway Energy's record
against any utility of the United States
petroleum you've watched it
well I have and uh
I'm not personally
at all sure how
bad the global warming is going to be I
think I don't think anybody knows for
sure whether seeds are going to rise two
inches or 20 feet
and
so I think there's a lot of faults
claims here in the world where much is
not known
yeah we
Wyoming
[Applause]
there is a lot of wind in Wyoming and we
are building trans Mission line to
extend out
through the west but
it was World War II and they told us to
do it and somebody and we had a czar and
in Washington could say you know just
get it done like I said the Henry Kaiser
I'm building ships you know you can't
believe how far ahead we would be down
from where we are but
we've got some money we've got the
know-how
and we do spend about
this year our depreciation and our
utility companies
on the order of four billion dollars and
we spend
maybe three billion additional left so
maybe we spend seven billion and uh
and there are very few companies in them
in the utility industry that are
spending you know that percentage of
their depreciate one but we'd love to be
spending more but there are people
there are people all over that
don't want they don't want the pipeline
to go through there they don't want to
tell if whatever it may be
and uh
that is the problem of a democracy and
and even as I mentioned within Iowa
you've got a great many counties that
majority great majority of the economies
I think but welcome
the wind power and you've got some
counties that don't like it and we're
obviously going to work with the ones
that don't want to work with us we do
not have the ability to go in and tell
anybody what to do on that uh and
there's a Public Utility Commission in
every state
uh that basically governs what we earn
on it what we do and that's the way the
industry is developing that's not bad
unless you get into things that that
that in effect uh you know extend
they're part of a Country-Wide system
rather than Statewide system
I think also that even if we weren't
worried about global warming it would
make sense too sure shift to Renewables
to conserve our hydrocarbons
there are certain things hydrocarbons
can do that nothing else can do
and they're only so much of them there
why not be cautious in conserving them
and and the cause they've got so much
more efficient too I mean the the
Winston I mean if you look at what we're
doing now uh those towers are way more
efficient and and but there's a lot of
a lot of people that are talking
uh that uh
did all my things that can't be done and
then there's there's a there's a lot of
nonsense in this field yeah you know if
you like nonsense this is the feel for
you no well we're but we're in the field
so I know I know okay Becky
this is a question from Monroe
Richardson
The Wall Street Journal reported in
March that oil producers are producing
less oil and may have reached their peak
in the Permian Basin given the major
positions of both Occidental Petroleum
and Chevron in the Permian would you
please explain the rationale for
berkshire's significant Holdings of both
those companies considering that future
outlook for oil there
well there's no question it's really
interesting about oil and Charlie knows
way more about all of them what when did
you
by that royalty and your Bakersfield or
whatever it is but that was before I met
you right yes no it wasn't before it was
but it was yes it was it's just before
you're right yeah and and
that got him early still paying me
seventy thousand dollars a year
what'd you pay for the a thousand
dollars yeah yeah now that's the
opposite of the Permian uh my dad
bought a thousand or fifteen hundred
dollars worth of royalties
uh
before he died in 1964 he left over my
mother my mother left him to her two
daughters and my older sister died and
my younger sister's here today and she
gets these
checks every month and she knows about
all these different fields and what
they're producing and
that's the that's the reality of half of
the oil production or something around
that
in the United States and then the other
half
uh the Shale and
and you know if you've gone to the
movies uh I never watched oil
you've never watched the things that are
pumping childish royalties in California
you you see these you see these gushers
of oil well in the Permian and I'm like
this should sink in on you and the first
day the first day when you bring in a
well uh
you know it may be 12 000 barrels or
maybe 15 000 barrels uh
and it's even it's dangerous that um
Occidental had one come into
I think in 19 000 barrels or something
like that one day
and
in a year year and a half that it
becomes probably nothing it it's just
it's a different business in effect and
the United States
it's interesting we use
whatever we use
maybe 11 or a fraction
what we produce at 11 a fraction million
barrels of oil equivalent a day but
if sales stopped I mean it would drop to
six million very fast well
just imagine taking 5 million barrels a
day out of the production
uh in the world and
uh and then we're also taking down our
strategic petroleum Reserve uh strategic
petroleum reserves the ultimate oil
field you don't have to drill it's just
we've got it it was supposed to be
strategic but but it gets involved in
politics and uh so
different kinds of businesses and
basically and and we like them
occidental's position in the
Permian and we'd
we wouldn't like that position that well
I got the minus one day it got the minus
thirty dollars or a barrel well that was
crazy of course but but if oil sells it
at X
you know you do very well and it was
also the half of action you know your
costs are the same and it doesn't change
the production and it doesn't work as
well but it also brings down the oil
production of the United States very
fast so
we don't know what oil prices will be
but we do very much
like
the Occidental position they have and
that's why we Finance them a few years
ago and it looked like it was a terrible
mistake uh when the oil Market just
totally collapsed and
and then it changed around and we bought
a lot of the common stock uh in the last
few months they've reduced
are preferred which wouldn't we don't
like obviously
we'd be disappointed in them if they
didn't reduce it uh it's intelligent
from their standpoint so we've taken of
the 10 billion dollar preferred we've
gotten maybe four or five hundred
million dollars of it retired at 110
percent of par but
uh
Vicky hollombe
uh is a she's an extraordinary
manager
of Occidental
her first job was with City service
that was the first stock I bought in
1942. uh
she knows what happens beneath the
surface
I know though
I know the
math of it but I wouldn't know I would
never find this idea what to do if I was
in an oil field I mean I don't I can dig
two defeat down I I can't in my backyard
and I can that's my
that's my understanding of subsoil in
the world I can't picture the field that
Charlie has been collecting that monthly
checked from
from 50 plus years 60. uh well 60 60
years roughly uh or my sister's getting
various Fields where they just keep
pumping and pumping and bumping in and
uh
we in the United States
are lucky to have the ability to produce
uh the kind of oil we've got from shell
but it is not
a long-term
source
uh like you might think by
by
watching movies about oil or something
of the sort Charlie Daniel yeah it
really dies fast so what those Shale
Wells
if you like quick death of the URL Wells
that we have them for you
no
but Occidental
uh they're doing a lot of good things
yeah they do a lot of new wells and yeah
they they're doing it in a profit but
it's it's a different kind of oil it's
just different yeah yeah and and that's
true of almost half the oil produced in
the United States
and uh
there's times more oil down there that
nobody knows how to produce and they've
been working at it for like 50 years but
they worked at the at the existing Shale
production for about 50 years before
they figured it out and it was weirdly
complicated when they finally were able
to do it
there's only one type of sand that works
can you imagine a horizontal
pipe you know that maybe a mile and a
half or something it's it's just so
different than what you think about uh
you can drive laterally for three miles
two miles down yeah how the hell do you
drill two or three miles laterally when
you're already two or three miles under
the Earth they've mastered a lot of very
tricky technology to be able to get any
oil out of these Wells at all
and we love them positioned with
Occidental and yeah we love having Becky
run it and uh they've been there's a lot
more oil down there if anybody can
figure out another magic trick that's
all we need is another magic trick
but Occidental have some other things
too yes yes but it does
but it the price of oil still is
incredibly important in terms of the
economics of short lived oil I mean no
question about that uh well if it's and
we we will incidentally
uh you know I
there's speculation about us buying
control we're not going to buy control
we don't want to we've got the right
management money and we can't we
wouldn't know what to do with it Charlie
wouldn't mind know what to do in
oilfield sitting here buying coal would
be like going out and seeking the
would acquire a cancer or something
you can't even borrow to expand a coal
mine now it's really it got very
unfashionable
yeah
and we think frankly some of the things
that are ridiculous and on both sides on
both in in both extremes I mean it's
just I mean you're dealing with physics
you're dealing with um you know it's
the politicization
of of positions of something that's
enormously important in terms of energy
is just uh it just lends itself to
demagogues and and fundraisers and
advisory organizations and everybody
inside but uh
and
we will make rational decisions and we
do not think it's an American to be
producing oil
and there is no
oil Basin in the United States than
compares to the Permian
in terms of Promise yeah we were lucky
well we didn't know it was there until
yes not that many years ago it has ever
been used up and they always knew that
shallow was there but they thought it
was going to stay unrecoverable forever
the second or third stock I bought was
Texas Pacific Land Trust and they owned
three million Acres down there and pee
and they were
there were grazing revenues of ten
thousand a year or something like that
they were sitting on this incredible
amount of oil and basically that company
is now actually part of Chevron and it
went through Texaco and did all kinds of
things and and they're still they're
still a Texas Pacific land trust but a
lot of that property is is fee fee owned
by by their minerals are owned by by
Chevron which is some Advantage but it's
uh
well it's an interesting subject I'll
put it that way and and we will not be
making any offer for control of oxy none
of it but we love the shares we have and
we may or may not
on more in the future but but we
certainly have warrants on on which we
got as part of the original deal on a
very substantial amount of stock at
around 59 a share and
and that moved once lasted a long time
and I'm glad we have them okay station
Seven
my name is Max Joe and from Toronto
Canada
I have a question for Charlie regarding
statement you made in the past
you once mentioned that you would prefer
to hire someone with IQ of 130 who
believes is 120 over someone with IQ of
150 who thinks is 170. understand that
you were referring to Elon Musk
given the recent success of his Ventures
such as Tesla SpaceX and starlink I'm
curious to know
if you still hold the view that Elon
Musk overestimate himself thank you so
much
[Applause]
well yes I think over Elon Musk over
estimates himself but he has a he is
very talented so he's he's over as
they're meeting somebody who doesn't
need to overestimate to be very talented
there's a Bill Maher
program about a week old maybe two weeks
old but but he interviews Elon and Elon
does a
terrific job
told us all with Bill Maher who I mean
it's worth watching and uh
elonism
he's a brilliant brilliant guy and I
would say that you know he might score
over 170 but but he
you know it's
he he dreams about things and and they
they his dreams have got a foundation he
would not have achieved
what he has in life if he hadn't tried
for unreasonably
extreme objectives
he likes taking on the impossible job
and doing it
we're different and I are looking for
the easy job that we can identify yeah
if we can do it playing Tic-Tac-Toe
we'll do it you know I mean
we have a totally different way of going
in the hallway yeah but we don't want to
compete with Elon and
a lot of things I mean you know we don't
want that much failure
[Applause]
yeah and
and
it takes over your life and I mean in a
way that it just doesn't fit us but but
you know they're going to be
well there have been important things
done by Elon already and and uh
it requires
fanaticism isn't the word yeah it is the
word okay
well it isn't quite the word but yeah
but but
it's a dedication
dissolving The Impossible and and every
now and then they'll do it and uh
but it would be torturous to Mayor
Charlie and uh
I like the way I'm living and and uh I
wouldn't enjoy being in this but he
wouldn't enjoy being in my shoes either
no
what's what's the Belmar interview
okay Becky
this question comes from Foster Taylor
um at the 2010 Berkshire annual meeting
you said the one question that you would
ask of the Berkshire CEO would be about
the distribution of cash to shareholders
as the Berkshire cash pile grows larger
and larger so let me ask that question
do you still feel confident of the
future prospects for our over 100
billion dollars in cash on hand or are
we getting closer to cash distributions
well
our our you know the one thing if
Berkshire Shares are selling for less
than we think they're worth
that's a pretty that could be a pretty
big uh
uh
whether to distribute cash that the Bob
we'd rather what we really like to do is
buy great businesses if we could buy a
company for 50 billion or 75 billion
uh 100 billion we could do it and we can
do it and our words good uh
it's difficult with a public company
because in effect if you've been on a
company uh
you make the bid and their shareholders
vote months later and that you're giving
an option
if we're good for it and the other guy
has a way to uh
topio or all kinds of things uh they can
get out of it and you you get paid two
percent for that or one percent for that
that is not an appropriate price and on
the other hand uh Delaware will decide
whether whether they should do it or not
and that's that's the way the world is I
mean that's that's the law so
be easier to do with a private company
and and there aren't very many that are
big on the other hand there aren't very
there's nobody else that can quite make
a deal like we can under certain under
the right circumstances and there could
be a situation
where
a bunch of very
a number of very decent companies
I've got a very uncomfortable
uh
uh borrowing structure and
money comes to do it due to them it's
the exact wrong time and that's when
they pick up a phone is dead
Tiffany and Harley Davidson and you name
it I mean a whole bunch of companies uh
in 2008 that sort of thing will happen
again whether
whether it results in us getting the
calls or what the world is exactly at
that time but the one thing we know is
that that the number of phone calls that
you can make at a time like that
is very very limited and it uh and and
uh there can be good companies they
don't want to sell the company
necessarily but they may want they just
may need
5 or 10 or 20 billion dollars depending
on what company you're talking about and
uh that can happen and our own
shareholders can be selling the stock
too cheap and we'll never do anything to
make them solid shape and we'll tell
them the truth about what the business
is but if Market circumstances result in
us being able to bind 50 billion of our
own stock we'll buy it uh so we'll see
what we'll see what the world holds but
I I don't I don't
we don't have the opportunities we used
to have but
we've got we've got enough and and we're
making money with what the things we
have it isn't killing a stole a hundred
and
Thirty billion of of
uh bills at five percent plus Bond
equivalent yields and everybody says
well yo yields are going to get out of
the future
I don't have a famous idea what else
we're going to do in the future and you
know the prime rate was 21.5 in 19. 81
or two and people were worried that it
was going to go totally out it's been
out of control
and Boker kept it from happening but if
Volker hadn't been in there who the hell
knows what would happen but uh so
we're running Berkshire so that uh we'll
do okay and maybe we'll do a little bit
better than okay
Charlie
okay maybe fine
okay station eight
hello Mr Buffet Buffett I'm Mr Monger my
name is Carlos Sanchez and I'm honored
to be here from Guadalajara Mexico
Mr Monger as a fellow lawyer I have a
question regarding corporate law
considering your experience and success
if you were to offer guidance to someone
like when he was at the beginning of his
career and before becoming bearshake
Hathaway company's lawyer
what key principles or lessons would you
suggest to help him excel in his
profession
well I'm not sure I quite caught all of
that
but
yeah what I don't think I have a lot of
advice about
How to Succeed as a lawyer
I have a
son-in-law who describes modern law
practice on a big firm
he says it's like a pie eating contest
where you win you get to eat more pie
[Laughter]
and I advise you to avoid that kind of a
offer
life is too short to just do nothing but
eat pie yeah
yeah Charlie is not practiced law
since what
1964 maybe or not whatever it was but
1962 62. and uh
Charlie has given me
four or five
pieces of advice
that don't really come
from his legal background
but
but because he knows the system so well
and
and you know really did
do quite well at Harvard Law School
despite his
[Laughter]
taunting of teachers and a few things uh
he has given me
four or five Solutions on things that
nobody else in the world
would have given me
Law Firm or otherwise and it and it's
it's been a within a set within us
almost a nanosecond of when I described
a problem to him
and they just gave me the answer that
nobody else would have come up with and
uh
I I told you one of them last year so I
won't repeat it at this meeting but but
it's uh
we've got the best lawyer in the world
and Charlie it was something that really
matters uh and uh uh there have been
times when
I've taken advantage of that uh
and
I
totally didn't want to be a lawyer he
didn't want to sell his time
maybe at 20 bucks an hour or something
to people he thought were making the
wrong decisions and he knew more about
it and they did and that just did not
strike him as a good way to go through a
life but I think he's probably right on
that I think he'd it had really gotten
to be miserable if he had to keep doing
that it's just no fun be like me giving
investment advice to somebody that or
taking it from somebody I had to you
know it just I just wouldn't want to do
in life and Charlie figured that out and
so we decided to work for ourselves and
this worked been happy happily ever
after
we have no complaints yeah none
uh
okay where is Becky
this question comes from Ryan Harding
and it's about the new 15 corporate
minimum tax rate as he sees it its
implementation is currently understood
he thinks it as he understands it to
apply over a rolling three-year periods
and to be based
on reported earnings first is the
inclusion of unrealized gains and losses
and reported earnings Under The Current
financial reporting standards contribute
to the calculation for corporate minimum
tax rate purposes and could it could
potentially convert some of those
notional deferred taxes Into Cash taxes
even if a rise in the market price of a
major holding is only Temple temporary
but rather extreme and then second could
it reduce the effect of some of the
renewable energy tax incentives and
others
yeah
I I think the answer on the second part
probably
is no but I don't want to say it is for
sure because uh
he's asking the same questions I Ask of
Mark Hamburg who's the
smartest guy on combining
understanding a business understanding
the tax code understanding SEC rules and
everything else uh that you'll find in
Corporate America and
and these questions that that the
particular question
uh on multiple security then uh I don't
think has been answered yet and I think
that there are a number of things about
the new tax act that were
not an accent but I would say this
uh
the I
you know we have said
ourselves what we think the proper
approach to
operating income we didn't design that
because this tax law came along with
some years back so we we're
we would think that you wouldn't include
capital gains unrealized capital gains
uh in
but
we
we've got enough
I I think no matter how things turn out
you know the 15 tax doesn't bother me in
the least and uh
we can figure ways once we know the
rules
where we will pay
the 15 tax
and
you know we were paying 52 percent taxes
federal income taxes one
I bought control in the partnership of
Berkshire Hathaway I mean the tax rate
come down dramatically and the Deferred
tax
that was embodied for example a Sanborn
map when I was involved in a system that
was allowed under the tax law to avoid
that tax but that was a huge tax 52
percent so we
we will let them we will live with this
tax code and we do not think
corporations are over taxed in the
United States and uh
you know and I think that
the conversation about how we lose out
to the world and all that sort of thing
it's really nonsense uh but uh we've got
we got a new law that hasn't yet the
regulations haven't been written on and
when when we know what the game is we
will absolutely figure out
a way to
pay 15 percent
every year and which generally we've
been paying anyway and as I I pointed
out
if there were a thousand corporations in
the United States that paid what
Berkshire has been paying nobody else in
the United States
no individual no Corporation would ever
pay any income tax Social Security tax
gift tax estate tax anything else
a thousand like Berkshire Hathaway would
produce the revenue that's being
produced by the federal government it's
being derived under the present tax code
from everybody in the United States and
I don't feel badly about that and I'd
love to get up to where it's one 500 or
something of the sort of done uh but I'd
like to do it
endorsed us right I'm happy to do it
I think we are privileged to live in the
United States
but we also have to control spending and
uh
that's something that
Congress doesn't quite widely like to
give like to do and they didn't like to
do it but my dad went to Congress but
but they've dug in more as the years
have gone by Charlie
well we would cover this subject earlier
yeah
okay
station nine
am I right on this yeah
my name is Avalon gross and I am from
Los Angeles California I am a
shareholder
and it's my fourth year coming to the
Woodstock of capitalism
yeah yeah we're glad you came
thank you so much for everything Warren
and buff Warren Buffett and Charlie
Munger
what is the funniest story that you have
never told about each other and also
what is the hardest part of your
business
I'll answer the second
[Applause]
second part of your question is that
that we don't have a heart business we
love our business every morning when I
get up
I feel good I don't know what's going to
happen that day
maybe nothing will happen but maybe
something will happen and if nothing
else I'll roll some t-bills or something
but it it uh I work I work with the
greatest group of people you can imagine
I mean we we uh we like each other and
nobody is after anybody else's job or
anything of the sort it's ideal working
conditions and it's five minutes from my
home or thereabouts uh so I haven't
spent my life commuting uh I just can't
imagine having it having anything better
and and
Charlie's got a lot of funny stories you
haven't heard but we'll see which one he
comes up with
well
I think Warren and I are naturally so
ridiculous that we don't need very many
funny stories
we each do things that are peculiar
enough so that we can keep one another
amused
tell them what you told the lawyer when
we were buying hostile cone
I don't remember you tell them well well
remember
it was nice I
and uh we were down in Baltimore buying
a department store and we needed a
lawyer
and we needed a lawyer who was nearby
and would do exactly as told and
Charlie came up with them
a very good lawyer from Wilma cutlers I
believe
and I don't know whether
Charlie remembers the instructions he
gave the lawyer or not
yeah no I don't oh well Charlie told the
lawyer
who we'd never met before and he said
well he just he says treat Warren like I
was
36 at the time or 35. he's a treat treat
worn like any other 90 year old glad
[Laughter]
this guy knew exactly what he meant and
uh we made the deal in a hurry and then
we
we went to the bank
the First National Bank and I believe it
was a Maryland National Bank actually
and there was a fellow named Cami slack
there wasn't it Charlie and we yeah we
wanted to borrow six million bucks
against a 12 million dollar purchase
and Cami looked at his house and would
bewilderment he says you want to borrow
six million dollars in this little old
hostel
and uh
Charlie and I said something to the
effect well the Maryland National was
our first call and if they didn't want
to do it we had another bank we'd go to
and anyway they allowed us the money but
but
when he said a little old wholesale coin
we immediately started thinking maybe
maybe this isn't the best deal we've
ever seen in our lives and from that
point on we were trying to figure out
how to sell it
so we've had but we
we had as much fun
uh Sandy got us one was involved with us
then too and we had as much fun
out of deals that didn't work in a
certain sense as the ones that did work
I mean it's it uh
you know if you knew you were gonna
play golf and you're going to hit a hole
in one on every ship hole you just hit
the ball and then went in the holes 300
yards away or 400 yards away he was
nobody'd play golf
I mean part of the fun of the game is
the fact that you had them into the
woods and sometimes you had to get them
out and sometimes you don't so we are in
the perfect sort of game and we both
enjoy it and we we have a lot of fun
together and and
we we don't have to do anything we don't
really believe in doing I mean we we are
not dictated to by by any
group uh and so we get to follow our own
we get to forge our own
Dustin Aaron and in a sense
towards the own principle by which we
can run the company and that's a huge
luxury in life and and we don't want to
be president of any other company in the
world or CEO or anything else or
we have to conform to certain things
that we really don't want to conform to
kind of fair description Charlie
yeah it is yeah
okay Becky
this question comes from David Cass who
is a professor at the business school at
University of Maryland he says at last
year's annual meeting Warren mentioned
that Berkshire had taken a large stake
in Activision Blizzard as a merger
Arbitrage play since the UK regulator
has blocked its acquisition by Microsoft
his Berkshire reduced or sold at stake
well I think in terms of what we do with
stocks
we don't give information except when
required to which is in the 13th out for
whatever we file and uh and there's some
there's certain things you can actually
figure out by looking at our 10
or 10q which we followed this morning uh
but you have to look pretty hard but um
I would say this
it's
I think Microsoft has been
remarkably
uh
what's the word uh
willing to
cooperate
with
governing bodies and I mean they want to
do the deal and they met them
the opposition it seems to me
more than halfway but
that doesn't mean
that it gets done if
if I've given country in this case the
UK
wants to park it there they're in a
better position to block it than the
United States but just the way the world
works and uh
that doesn't get solved by offering more
money or so it it um
I don't know how it
how it turns out
uh
but if it doesn't go through I don't
think it's through any
short coming by either
Microsoft or Activision uh
but
not everything that should happen does
happen and uh uh well we weren't we ran
into it when we
when we bought
what made the deal with Dominion Energy
18 months ago and that they let us buy
a good bit of what we wanted to buy and
then
and then
there was government in effect said you
can't buy something else which I think
we would have done a better job with
them anybody else did and which the
States involved they're not object to it
which the customers didn't object to it
but
you don't
you don't take on the United States
government you know and and
you try and figure out things that that
you won't have a problem with and uh
I think in that case the NOS government
made a mistake I think the British
government's making a mistake in this
case but
but that's that's life in the big cities
sure I would say and uh
what we do will depend on a lot of
things
Charlie
well I think
what we do
yeah we
you kissed that one off beautifully
okay station 10.
hi Warren uh hi Charlie my name is
Anderson Fuller and I'm from avonport
Nova Scotia in Canada and before I ask
my question I just want to thank you for
all you've done to give us insight into
your minds as investors
um so for me the most compelling
takeaway from Berkshire is your guys's
emphasis on and successful use of
properly aligned incentives in my view
owning and leading a business has two
Central benefits first you directly
benefit as the company goes through your
equity in it and second you have
autonomy incentives for employees are a
bit easier to understand such as
offering benefits Fair pay and creating
a strong culture but I've always
struggled to understand them at the
highest level even though you say
Berkshire gives its managers significant
flexibility it must be less than what
they had when they were independent
Additionally you would think passion and
a willingness to sell would be inversely
correlated so how exactly does Berkshire
Bridge's Gap and incentivize owners of
its subsidiaries to give up these
benefits to Berkshire thank you well
what we really hope to find
is managers who love their business
but don't
like a lot of what comes with it
as a public company I mean if they have
to spend a lot of time listening to
people
tell them what to do about this or that
and they can't afford to irritate them
uh
or they have to
go along with their
trade Association because or what you
know whatever they may call it
um because you don't want to look like a
free rider and then there's all kinds of
things
compromises that people have to make in
most jobs
and uh
Charlie and I
solved that problem I had five bosses in
my life
and I liked all five of them and two of
them were just huge factors
and making my life better but I like all
five of them a couple of them are you
know
some people here
JCPenney Cooper Smith you know I worked
with 75 cents an hour and I love them I
love working at Penney's well I didn't
love working at pennies out but I love
working
for uh
Cooper Smith and and uh you know it was
75 cents an hour but I had
I had to do what they told me to do
which was to sell men's shirts first
then men's clothing then children's
clothing and so on and uh I love working
for the newspaper and
I had a great manager when I was
University of Nebraska got to work for
Ben Graham I made everything worked out
but
it there's nothing like working for
yourself and if you can't own a big
company
working at Berkshire Hathaway
for running a company
uh is the closest thing you will get you
don't have to spend time
according analysts who
you'll probably have contempt for uh in
many cases you don't have to spend time
with banks you know getting money and
and particularly in terrible times yeah
there's all kinds of
you get a lot
in the way of Freedom then
I would think would be meaningful
to me and it might be better if you own
the whole place yourself but maybe
you've got siblings that want out maybe
there's a million reasons why you may
not be able to achieve that
uh unless you some
uh to Berkshire and
uh that's easier probably if you have a
family business where people want to go
in different directions than it is with
a public company but
there's still possibilities there so
that's that's why
that's why I
I think if I owned a public company
and it was worth many great many
billions of dollars
and Berkshire Hathaway
wanted to buy it
and the shareholders were willing to
vote it
uh
I would
consider the way I would feel about life
but one thing I wouldn't want to retire
at 65. I'd want to keep working and uh
uh
that I'm waiting
we just we there's there are reasons
that saw the Berkshire which Charlie and
I
in certain positions if we were on the
other side would take the deal and
and uh uh but it isn't for everybody
Charlie
I think we have a pretty good one
we've been very lucky Ian
and
I don't know
it seems to me that most of the people
are going to end up the way we did
they almost already know how to do it
well the most important purchase in
retrospect that we may have made was
National Indemnity not because
specifically what it did but what it led
to
and Jack Ring Mall control the company
and I know a woman liked them and and uh
he knew me and once a year
he'd get irritated
uh when the Nebraska Department of
Insurance or somebody would come come
around and he said they always came
around when the Aksarben racetrack was
open you know so they could I mean he
had all these theories about why
it was a pain in the neck
to be regulated and I
and I told Charlie heider next time
Jack is in that mood where he's ready to
sell just because he's tired of fooling
around with all these guys
be sure and find them and so
Charlie called me one day and he says
Jack is in the Heat and I said bring him
over and we made a deal well that's why
Jack sold and he was happy after he made
the deal and I was happy after we made
the deal so there's a man that
controlled the business
but just decided these people didn't
seem to bother him as much once they
were my problem and not his and you just
can't tell when lightning will strike
and and that didn't do magnificent
things for us initially but just look at
what it led to you know and then uh so
you never
you know if you knew if you knew how you
were gonna again if you know how you're
gonna shoot all 18 holes it wouldn't be
any fun playing you wouldn't get on the
First Tee I mean it's it's
the
it's the uncertainty the fun of playing
the game the opponents all kinds of
things that make a game interesting and
and I think Charlie or are in the most
interesting game in the world
okay Becky
here's a question from Simon Withers in
Perth in Western Australia
it's been a long time since we've heard
about See's candy and netjets could you
please give us an update on C's
performance and when you project it
we'll run out of places to open stores
in the United States and could you also
give us an overview of how netjets has
performed since its acquisition and
whether it's achieved the potential you
saw at the time of that acquisition
well
with seeds it hasn't been a question of
opening stores we found out that we
we've tried about we've had this
wonderful
brand that doesn't travel you know uh
the Mystique
the actual product
the feelings people have about some
things as we said before I mean it
sometimes it's
it's limited to giving Marcus Dr Pepper
sells at a huge rate in Dallas Fort
Worth and maybe I'm maybe 10 times the
percentage per capita maybe that it has
in Detroit or Boston and you say well
how can that be with the product's been
around for a century and people travel
and you have National advertising and
I'm not sure but I I kept learning more
as I watch different brands and Charlie
and I
our economics were so good
in California that we tried to
in many cases the same experiment over
and over again it doesn't cost much to
experiment we've tried everything in the
world
Doom close the band brand to travel
and we always think we were right for
the first week and then we find out that
that
the magic
we can we can beat any other candy store
pretty much but there aren't any candy
stores anymore to speak of as the world
has changed so
uh
sees
is a
101 years now it has magic
and it has limited Magic
and sort of the adjacent West you can
almost as gravitational almost and and
then uh
you get to the East and incidentally in
the east
people prefer dark chocolate them
to milk chocolate in the west people
prefer milk chocolate to dark the
easting saw managers in dark the West I
mean there's all kinds of crazy things
in the world that consumers do but you
want to keep observing it because you do
learn a little
and with Charlie and I'm
sorry the the
temptation to keep trying things because
the economics were so good if we
succeeded so we tried
various things and of course every
manager wants to try as it comes along
because they 've learned you know it
should work but it doesn't work so
but that's that's what makes it very
interesting in netjets
we
we have really
learned how to distinguish
and justifiably distinguish
uh
a service
at the people so that
if you can
you have to be very well to do
to use it but if you're very well to do
you're in effect you're you're spending
your errors
money I mean it's what I told my Aunt
owls after she went from teaching to be
worth
millions of millions of dollars and she
came to see me
she never been married and she she said
can I afford to buy this for a coat in
1968 or nine and I said Alice you aren't
buying it your nieces and nephews are
buying it because that's who you're
leaving your money to and speaking on
behalf of your nieces and nephews I've
said we want you to buy it and it's the
same way you know do your heirs want you
to fly around an address or do you want
to leave a little more money to your
foundation or your kids and and where to
solve that one is to offer your kids a
few hours themselves and
then their attitude can change so it's
it's it's in a class by itself it's it's
done what Ferrari has done in a
different sort of way
in cars Ferrari sells 11 000 cars a year
I mean maybe twelve thousand and you
know they're known throughout the world
and we'll have a Chevy dealership in
Austin or something we'll sell as many
cars but we're not Ferrari and netjets
has 600 and
well the county Europe I mean it's maybe
651 we're going to buy 100 planes this
year and we won't sell any because we've
got a backlog and we took we took a
nutshell flight over to Tokyo and we
arrived in
good shape and we spent a couple days
there we flew back and there's just
nothing to it now you can say well
you're getting sort of decadent and all
that in your old age but
uh
the money will go to philantha being
though
the money will probably be 100 billion
or more and and I forget the
philanthropies want me to spend a few
bucks on myself and all it has to do is
be better than the last dollars that are
spent by various Florence a piece which
have plenty of problems finding things
to do that make lots of sense so uh
not just there isn't a competitor I mean
we've looked at
the other day
wheels up
stock came out of ten dollars
uh
a couple years ago I was selling at 48
cents the other day and they got 12 600
people
they've given a bill a billion dollars
a little over a billion dollars on
prepaid
prepaid cards where they they've given
them money and they get a certain number
of hours later on and uh
they don't
I think there's a good chance that that
some people are going to be very
disappointed later on when they have
money then
doing that Jets they
they know we'll get
they'll get on the same planes with the
same Pilots
uh as I am my family
have flown on since before we bought the
company so it's not it's not shaped but
it wasn't the decision was shaped by
some commercial
uh objective
a couple years before
I never heard of Matt Johnson Frank
Rooney mentioned it to me and I've
watched Sharon share immediately and and
we bought the company and and
every
welcome my kids have to fly a commercial
sometimes but sometimes they get to use
ours too but
I've never flown anything else and why
would I I mean it's it's it's the goal
Center and uh
uh nobody will
match our Fleet I mean if you've got you
know 600 planes you've got them a lot
more places in the United States than
that anybody else will have theirs I
think we're the second largest Fleet
counting the commercial airliners and
and our fleet's growing like I said
the rate of 100 Lanes a year or
something
it's a marvelous company and
Adam Johnson has performed
uh
you just can't believe what he's done
with the business and it was a tough
model for a long time
but he's brought a word is and we've got
we should have a wonderful company for
forever
Charlie
well that just has been remarkable you
can argue that it's worth as much as any
Airline now
oh it's so different and Charlie we had
a hard time selling Charlie and that
just membership and then we figured the
way to get him
to buy a membership was to put a coach
seat in the fuselage
and that really knocked him off I mean
I think he's the only one we sold on the
basis I used to come to the Berkshire
annual meetings on coach
from Los Angeles and it was full of Rich
stockholders and they would clap when I
came into the coach section I really
like that
[Applause]
but I got to tell you we semi-corrupted
him he he he he
he feels he kind of has to explain it
but he still flies up and
be crazy not to you know it's uh and
your errors are paying for it I mean if
you find me anybody
who's a state
came in at less than zero because what
they spend in
on that Jets
threw them into that position
uh let me know but I've I've never seen
a case yet it won't be the case for the
Buffett Valley and and it's the residual
bottom beneficiary that's paying uh for
your uh your membership and and uh
it's a little hard to get used to paying
that much money though when you look
like Charlie and I have most of my life
okay
we will go to uh section 11.
hello my name is Humphrey Liu I'm from
Charlottesville Virginia ah
first I wanted to ask to wanted to add
my thanks to you and
Mr Munger and Mr Buffett and all of
Berkshire for throwing this Grand Event
each year
looking at the global Trends it
increasingly does seem that zero Mission
Vehicles may have finally reached the
cusp of mass adoption
do you see any opportunities in this
space either in specific vehicle
manufacturers or in related Technologies
well I would say that that Charlie and I
for longer felt that the
Auto industry is just too tough
you know the Ford Motor Company I mean
Henry Ford
uh
looked like he owned the world
with the Model T and then
and he brought down the price
dramatically he took up wages
dramatically he was
he might have been with a different
personality ah
or some different views he might have
been elected president of the United
States I mean there's a good book that
came out on that recently that told
about the story of one of them tell us a
little about Nebraska in terms of it but
Henry Ford and and
Thomas Edison joining up
but maybe a year or two was it if you're
interested in
in Autos you ought to read that book but
Henry Ford did that and
you know and 20 years later
that uh they were losing money and they
had a guy with a gun in his pocket I
think Harry Bennett you know it was was
running the Ford Motor Company it was on
its way to the junkie when the whiskers
came in and
and Henry Ford II Hank the deuce as they
call them brought in Tex Thornton and my
friend RJ might learn a few people but
it's just
it's not
I've read that I was reading the other
day actually the 1932 annual report of
General Motors and uh it's one of the
best annual reports I've I've read it's
a totally honest you know assessment of
exactly where they were they had 19
000 dealers then
and the population as I mentioned
earlier was about 120 million or so and
now with 330 million people all brands
in the United States have like 18 000
dealers or something
it's just a business where you've got a
lot of worldwide competitors they're not
going to go away
and they'll look like it looks like
there are winners at any given time but
it doesn't get you a permanent place
although as I mentioned I would say
Ferrari is in a special place
but I only saw 11 or 12 000 cars a year
and uh
us last year I think there were 14
million something and uh uh
it's it's not a business where we find
it fascinating to be in we like our
dealership operation
but I don't think I can tell you what
the Auto industry will look at look like
five or ten years now I do think that
you're right that that that
you know there's a you will see a change
in the vehicles but you won't see
anybody that owns the market because
they changed the vehicle Charlie
well the electric vehicles
coming big time
and that's a very interesting
development at the moment it's
imposing huge Capital costs and huge
risks
and I don't like huge Capital costs and
huge risks
and we're subsidizing in the United
States and we're actually doing it try
putting in a pro labor time I mean it's
it is subject to politics like you can't
believe it too but but it's it's going
to be with us we're not going to quit
we're driving cars and American public
has a love affair with them and uh
but
I
I think I know
where Apple's going to be in five or ten
years and I don't know whether the car
companies are going to be in five or ten
years and I may be wrong but that's uh
uh
we
Charlie and I follow the auto business
with
with intense interest Charlie's firm
was the specialist in General Motors on
the Pacific coast Stock Exchange and
that was that was a franchise it wasn't
it Charlie
yeah we get by working very hard we can
make a minor amount of money
yeah yeah it wasn't minor at the time
but it was it wasn't fired at the time
even yeah
well that was pretty minor okay Becky
this question comes from Lindsay Peter
Schumacher in Cedar Rapids Iowa
does the current size of the Federal
Reserve balance sheet concern you in
particular the result of quantitative
easing the Federal Reserve expanded its
balance sheet out of nothing the net
effect in essence is a form of single
entry accounting creating something of
value out of nothing other than a series
of book entries Andre uh entries and
wondering what Mr Munger thinks about
this as well
well I don't think the Federal Reserve
is the problem and I think they can't
solve
the fiscal problem
uh and
uh I don't I don't I do not worry about
the Federal Reserve and uh uh I think
it's
fulfilling the functions for which it
was established I probably would not
have been
if they only they have two objectives
and I would not have been
one probably that would have changed the
inflation objective to two percent a
year from
from zero I I think that
that uh you know I think
that if you tell you people that you're
shooting to depreciate your currency at
two percent a year
uh that is
a lot of implications although it feels
good to a lot of people a lot of people
want a little inflation
uh but nobody wants a lot of inflation
except somebody's got a lot of deaths
and uh
uh
uh I I do not worry about
the Federal Reserve balance sheet I I
enjoy looking at it and the numbers are
big I always like big numbers but but uh
it is not it's interesting the most one
one of the most interesting figures to
me is currency in circulation I mean it
is gone they were saying cash is trash
back in 2007 and eight and all that cash
is going to disappear well
if you look at the Federal Reserve
balance sheet it's gone from 800 billion
to two point
two trillion
and most of us in hundred dollar bills
overwhelmingly and I figured out I think
there's about fifty one hundred dollar
bills per person babies everybody in the
United States and uh
I would really like to know where
all of that is I mean it nope nobody's
hoarding Euro dollars you know in South
America
Africa or whatever and uh
the demand for currency now
you know it's
somewhat maybe usually subtle drug
dealers
uh activities and all of that but
anybody thinks cash is trash
Auto uh look at the
look at the Federal Reserve balance
sheet and actually you can look at how
many five dollar bills and two dollar
bills and
ones and all that and the action has
been in one in 100 bills I mean it was
it is just astounding
the way up 100 bills
spreading and of course we don't know
whether I don't know where they are and
I don't think the FED can know exactly
but they probably make a lot better
guess than they could
but I do know what's happened and you
can watch it every week and you'll watch
currency in circulation
probably grow a little bit and uh
and believe me cash is not trash
Charlie
well I don't know where we're headed
with all of this
it's been very extreme
I think that you you could be pretty
extreme in fighting depressions and so
forth if you were versioned afterwards
to a period of some discipline
but
some discipline but if you're going to
just keep
borrowing your printing money and
spending it
I think eventually it causes bad trouble
and
you can see it in Latin America Latin
America let its currency get out of
control all the time and of course it
lagged the United States an economic
achievement greatly
so I think we pay a price if we
if we ever give up our old ways entirely
and go into a new world where we just
try and print money to make it easier to
get make to get through the air
we paid a price
in World War II
I mean everybody
school kids and everybody else myself
included I'm with we bought our work
originally called
war bonds and defense bonds and savings
bonds and all that but but
from 1940
due to the 1944 or five you paid out
1875 and you got 25 back and every kid
save savings and Samson all that but
when you got all through
you know
you had
120 percent of GDP in the national debt
instead of 30 or 40 percent
and we had a lot of inflation
subsequently a lot so the people
that really that bought those bonds and
supported the war
had a portion of their purchasing power
taken away from them well there wasn't
anything wrong with that particularly
but
one of the country gets in the habit of
doing that
uh
I don't think it's I think it's tough to
tough to figure out where the breaking
point is with Society but I don't think
it want to come anywhere close to it
it's also tough to have a massive people
unemployed
that's the tension
yep
well let's
that's why the
pet us to objectives in terms of
employment and inflation and uh
but they are not the ones that
great that officers and
so far the system has worked pretty well
although like I say it's been so far the
man who's jumped off a tall building
yeah it's all right until he hits the
ground yeah
well but but you there could be ways we
can stop now at the third floor or the
sixth floor we don't know what Ford is
but we know what this hasn't happened at
the ground but the question
you know politically it's very very very
tempting
to
to both Appropriations and it's not fun
vote taxism Russell long has the Senate
finance committee they've got a building
they matter from now he said you know
don't tax you don't tax me tax like are
behind the tree and basically that is
the attitude of uh I mean it's the
reality
of what is useful
in politics and so far those countries
managed to
work very well with a lot of things that
could theoretically cause a lot of
problems but it doesn't mean it doesn't
guarantee us the future on it and and
being the reserve currency
let's just do a lot of things but it
also creates a lot of consequences if we
screw it up
Charlie
well
we're bidding is subject to death but by
it is a problem I wish we had a solution
okay well that we'll go to station one
and see if we
hello uh Mr Buffett and Mr Munger my
name is Connor I'm an economic student
at the University of Nottingham
my question for you today is during the
pandemic we witnessed supply chain
shortages especially from Asia as a
result companies have chosen with
political attentions to move production
away
should companies make these decisions
and should the government support them
okay well that's a good question yeah
obviously
yeah
it's logical if you're in business and
you can make the thing in Mexico way
cheaper
it's natural to open a factory in
Mexican and in Mexico and
get your parts cheaper and a lot of the
auto manufacturers have done exactly
that
on the other hand
nobody wants to hollow out the whole
country so all the manufacturing jobs
are elsewhere and we're all living a
bunch of farmers
you know like English colonies in 1820
or something
and
these ideas are of course in
in big tension
uh
we have
we don't have that much foreign
production
all right Warren
yeah well
but we've lost
well originally Berkshire Hathaways the
textile manufacturer it lost because the
South became feasible versus the North
and of course then eventually uh the
South got expensive compared to China
sure and
and
uh
Society benefits and some people get
killed in that sort of a situation and a
rich Society
should take care one way or another
and of
people who worked in our shoe factories
people worked in our textile companies I
mean if you worked in our textile
operation and
in 1960
or when we took it over half our half
our workers only spoke Portuguese
and uh
you know they and they weren't getting
great wages at all
but now you could do it in the South and
we were doomed
to go out of business
and it wasn't the fall of the worker in
any way shape or form it wasn't the hard
fault we kept trying to compete well it
was a TVA had cheap power down there and
a textiles really congealed power and
air conditioning changed everything but
the Heat and those damn Pleasures were
impossible that's a lot of things but
then then it moves
uh offshore in many ways and and
now
the country is better off because of it
but it displaces a lot of people
who really can't do something else in
life you can't talk about retraining
somebody that's 55 or 16 speaks only
Portuguese and really tell them they're
going to have a great future a New
Bedford Mass and you know and and
so you don't want to be glib about it
and we can afford
to take care of those people
and we've got some systems that work
reasonably well but but there's a
tension between you know what about the
person that doesn't do anything and all
that kind of stuff so these are not easy
problems to solve but I would say
that by and large we want the whole
world to prosper we do not want to be a
world
we don't want the United States
to be a country of extraordinary
prosperity and have the rest of the
world starving no it it it it isn't
going to work and particularly it's
going to work in a nuclear world so
and you can have your own feelings about
it as a Humane person but but uh it
doesn't it it it does not
it it can be done better and and we've
got the resources to do it I mean
the output of this country what can be
done with a lot fewer people and and
doing more specialized things in the
course that has been the work week in
the United States
you know in my lifetime has dropped
dramatically and people
still feel busy and it will be the human
lot to say you know
how can I get all these things done but
but
my mother didn't drive three kids any
place so if you want to go in a place
if you were lucky he hadn't got old
enough he had a bicycle the world just
keeps looking at everything moving up as
becoming sort of a base that leaves them
somewhat dissatisfied and
with our prosperity
uh we can do a lot of things
we couldn't do it in 1930 and including
taking care of people that got
displaced by the fact that somebody else
can do that work and and improve their
lot in life and we got to make sure that
we have the best system that takes care
of the people who
who get displaced by that but
doing that and building a system we have
and everything will make a lot of
mistakes along the way but we got to
keep moving in that direction
and I'm really interesting thing about
it is that the
Adam Smith was right that the the
free market capitalism
automatically with a lot of property and
private hands and free trade and all
that automatically
creates GDP per capita that grows and
helps everybody including the people at
the bottom
it helps everybody a lot
but a inherent in the process
there's a lot of pain in that free
market capitalism for instance of the
Portuguese workers and the taxable
company in New Bedford
and nobody's ever figured out how to
take all the pain out of it we do have
government safety nets to take some of
the pain out we make those safety nets a
little bigger as time goes by
but apart from that
if you try and take all the pain out
you'll also take all the gains out of it
you won't carry growing GDP per capita
you'll have an economy like Russia's
which has been characterized as saying
they pretend to pay us and we pretend to
work
yeah the other systems haven't worked
better but yeah it also produces more
and more disparities
in wealth and people that
do nothing but
got assets under management without
actually performing anything extra make
fortunes and I mean
it's it's a job of government to keep
the best aspects of capitalism while not
causing people that only speak
Portuguese to suffer in the process I
mean the two aren't compatible
politically over time and we stumble
along making progress on things like
Social Security and all that and and
we are a lot better off than we are when
I was born net the United States has
done a very good job of this tension
between capitalistic growth and growing
social safety net we can be pretty proud
of our country Looking Backward
that may be why we have 25 percent of
the world's GDP starting with a half a
percent of the population and in a few
centuries I mean it's just it's a
miracle
it wasn't because we were smarter
oh you got to say that there must be
something to the system that's worked
pretty well even though it's produced a
Civil War and all kinds of things you
know and women you know not getting a
shot at anything you know even after
they passed the the
19th Amendment uh it's it's
a work in progress I think actually
there's been progress but it's Mankind's
nature to
to see the see the things wrong with it
if you've
a few words expansion Asia to take the
progress as a right not something to be
earned or strived for
but something that should automatically
just flow in over the transom
and that attitude is what is poison
it doesn't do anybody any good
okay now ask us an easy question Becky
this question comes from Doug deshield
since the accounting rules changed
requiring Berkshire to report the change
in fair value of its Equity Investments
through the income statement Mr Buffett
has repeatedly told shareholders to
ignore those changes as they're not
reflective of the long-term returns that
those investments will produce
recently Mr Buffett has argued that hold
to maturity accounting used by the Banks
to avoid reflecting the changes in fair
value of Bank investment portfolios in
the income statement and the shareholder
Equity account do a disservice to its
various stakeholders can Mr Buffett
elaborate on why he views Mark to Market
accounting differently for banks in
comparison to Berkshire oh I believe in
in both cases in doing it on the balance
sheet and not in the income statement
and and it's a very tough problem with
the Auditors face as is that
the
obviously the income statement feeds
into the balance sheet but the balance
sheet tells you
whether deposits can be paid it tells
you a lot of things and we show it on
our balance sheet we believe in showing
Market values on our balance sheet we
just don't believe in running it through
the income account and uh in getting
there we would put another comprehensive
income like it was for a long time so I
I sympathize to some extent
with the oh a far extent with the
audit group but they have to really
decide whether they want to
they want the balance sheet
to represent values except it doesn't
reflect them on the upside if we buy a
Seas Canyon it's worth way more money so
it's conservative in that sense
but uh
or whether they want to have a
an income account that becomes
meaningless to people
because it it really changes every five
seconds you know I mean while we're
all the Market's closed today but but uh
you know we have days well I guess Apple
was up what
seven or eight points I'm in on Friday I
mean that's seven billion dollars I mean
uh
that's a crazy income account it is a
reflection of where we stand at that
point and of course if you're a bank
where you're putting out money brilliant
and things that
people sort of mortgages I mean
primarily uh
uh they're a terrible instrument for a
bank to own but a great instrument for a
consumer to buy and build into the whole
society now in a way that was entirely
different than the past
uh you've got to pay attention to
whether
whether they've gotten out of whack in
terms of of
what the value of what they own and what
can be demanded of them tomorrow morning
and if we had all of our money this
could be demanded from us tomorrow
morning we'd have to behave a lot
differently than than Berkshire does
so I
I don't I don't
I really think the way to do it is the
way
we recommend doing which is exactly what
was being done until a few years ago I
recommend the shareholders look at it
that way but we're going to follow the
rules obviously the SEC
uh you know State authorities and
everybody require of us but I'll still
explain to the shareholders exactly what
I would explain to my sister about what
really counts of Berkshire and I think
every management actually has
an obligation to that and instead of it
they go in the other direction and give
them a lot of figures that are total
nonsense you know I can't imagine
some of the you know EBA da I thought
was about as bad as you could get but
they kept going you know earnings before
everything uh Ebe
and so uh
uh but that doesn't change but I would
tell my sister who's here in the
audience I hope uh and uh I should tell
us all the shareholders and we'll we'll
consistently do
what is legal and we'll consistently say
what we think is right
sorry
yeah
[Applause]
we want owners who understand what they
own
now that doesn't mean they have to
understand the detail of it but that's
why we have people that have been around
50 or 60 years that doesn't mean that
they read the 10 cues or anything like
that but they
they they feel we're telling it to them
like
you know hello next door to us yeah I
don't know what the accountants were
thinking when they made that change
it strikes me as Bonkers absolutely
bonkers
I don't see how anybody who understands
how businesses really operated and
should be operated by owning managers
would have made that accounting change
the accounts did it just because they
had a
wild moment
20 25 years ago I suggested the audit
progression that they just that the auto
committee asked Auditors four questions
and uh
the shareholders would know a lot more
about the company if those questions
were asked
but it wasn't good for the Auditors to
be asked those questions because it
might increase their liability if they
if they answered them and the client
didn't want them to answer them because
the man even didn't want them to no they
were they want a system where if they
follow certain rules they're safe
and that's understandable
but I don't think the
past year this rule requiring
changes in marketable Securities to go
through the income account quarterly
they didn't do that to protect
themselves from no liability they just
did that for some crazy reason
of Their Own
you get a bunch of people who are all
being drawing a lot of pay out of a big
complicated system and
rising in like so many officers in the
army God knows what they'll do if you
put them in a little room by themselves
and tell them to invent new accounting
standards
well to our order to remember that's
Charlie talking and that's right
but I agree with them 100 like he's 99
he can get away with more than I can get
away with
okay
station two
but what he said is enormously important
I mean it just you got to have some
insights into what the hell really goes
on and and even if you're a counting
accountant yeah okay station two
do you want dear Charlie
my name is Victoria runtrop I am 22
years old and I study in Munich at the
cdtm the center of digital technology
and management
as your grandchildren are more in my age
group let me ask you
how do you transfer your wisdom to your
grandchildren and heirs
how do you lead them to investing
do you see value in investing as a
family or individually thank you
I'm gonna let Charlie do the answering
he's got more well I have my
grandchildren but
I am quite philosophical about my
grandchildren not thinking exactly the
way I do
it seems to me that's almost a natural
course of life
and
I just live my life my own way and they
can observe it as an example if they
want to and if they don't they can try
some other way
I don't like it when they try some other
way
[Laughter]
to pretend that I like some of the
boyfriends and girlfriends I don't like
but I just struggle through like
everybody else
and usually I just bite my tongue and
keep silence that's my way of handling
it
well I would say that I think that my
case my three children have grown a lot
smarter in the last 30 years and I think
I've grown smarter and and I know but
you needed a lot of help that is for
sure
no I I would totally acknowledge that
that's why I had the room to go I mean I
I had plenty of room for improvement but
but I all had a lot to grow I went to I
worked a year for U.S steel which was in
there
uh fabrication department in Los Angeles
a big operation
the thing was utterly doomed and three
years later it went back to Greenfield
the whole thing was raised to the ground
I did not see it coming
now I would like to be that ignorant of
that
as I was at that age
it was a sin and my professors by and
large were even more ignorant than I was
we we just know what he had observed
the basic economics of business
in a scientific way at all when I was
young I was young well if we're getting
into confession time I have to tell you
it's 3 30. so we don't want to keep
going on who knows what we'll be saying
another half hour so yeah
so I thank you all very much for coming
at 4 30 we will have the shareholders
meeting here and the the we're
continuing to sell goods for another 20
or 25 minutes we've already broken all
kinds of Records but let's really make
it tougher comparisons next year and I
think again I thank you for coming come
next year and maybe we'll figure out the
answer to a few more of these questions
[Music]
thank you